c'est un type il est dans une boîte et
wayne fille d'une beauté un sens et
blanc magnifique lac dessin d un
décolleté abyssal et 10 o'gorman s'cusez
moi j'imagine que on est à cannes je
sois c'est une milliardaire intouchable
c'est une professionnelle et le barman
du ritz
c'est une professionnelle vous pouvez y
aller déjà le tipi dit je peux vous
offrir un verre a pris de plaisir je me
suis laissé dire que on pourrait avoir
un contact facile avec vos la fédé n'est
pas inexact et vous avez une grille
tarifaire par exemple si je voulais
juste une petite branlette lycée 1000
euros il y le rôle implique deux mille
euros c'est cher quand même me direz dit
venez avec moi
puissante et sur le parking et une
ferrari vous voyez cette ferrari je me
la suis payé toutes des bandelettes
voilà c'est la ferrari branlette 1000
euros je veux qu'il y va c'est la plus
belle boulette de sa vie extraordinaire
éteindre le téléphone de la fille et une
semaine après il est clair et il
économise un peu il à revoir eddy moi là
je vois pas celle à la vitesse
supérieure pour un jour une pipe
alors il pas de problème c'est 5000
euros avait 5000 euros la pipe à les
regarder
vous voyez là l'appart front de mer à
cannes duplex sa 800 m² avec les pipes
le maquis cent cinq mille euros c'est la
plus belle pub de tout cela
extraordinaire il économiser 400 pel et
ils empruntent à des potes et il revient
quelques jours après 18h at elle dit oui
c'est des 1000 euros fait dix mille
euros
elle regarde tu vois le yacht là-bas de
80 mètres là sur le port il fait alors
et basso yacht
si j'avais une chatte il serait à moi
[Applaudissements]
mais si les bras
la junte était propre
alors moi j'ai grenouille la femme veut
acheter un mât un cadeau d'anniversaire
son mari et on en magasin et des
grenouilles zych ses origines à une
grenouille est pas et grenouilles à 200
300 euros une grenouille à 5000 euros
allez un petit peu intrigué dit aux
vendeurs dites moi pourquoi cette
grenouille calais comme les autres et
est mignonne et j'en dis mais pourquoi 5
mélo et les vendeurs et dim à ce qu
elles sucent c'est pas comme une
princesse
ah ouais ça me fait même la peine de la
vente je vous le dis même à 5000 euros
et je la lis je prends c'est pour mon
mari ce pour sur l'anniversaire point la
grenouille elle ramène la grenouille et
son mari ne lui dit rien de ce secret tu
vois ils vont se coucher puis à 3 heures
du matin elle te lire son mari n'est
plus là et a longtemps un barouf
infernale dans la dans la cuisine ça
descend taxer rôle de chantre [ __ ] ya
des gamelles qui cuisent aux québécois
et de la farine qui veulent et où la
grenouille est là en train de rouler la
pâte et houleux des deals un bouquin les
mains dit cherry qui fut fait et 10
agents si elle arrive à me faire cette
recette
toi tu dégages
[Rires]
c'est le pays
elle est très très près les banques
soient les propres bon coco c'est c'est
dans un immeuble c'est une vieille dame
qui rentre dans l'ascenseur et comme sa
fenêtre elle est très très vieille très
vieille et direction soeur comme le font
pas c'est la gueule non parce que l'oeuf
était plus comme ça l'ascenseur
souverain et acheter une très belle
blonde qui rentre comme ça tu vas gens
posent instagram et qui se retourne vers
la vie' lui dit dior 100 euros la
bouteille et la porte se referme ça
descend d'un étage il ya une autre fille
blonde très belle encore plus belle qui
hante encore plus parfumé qui regardent
la vieille dame griffée chanel 300 euros
la bouteille et ça arrive au
rez-de-chaussée
la porte s'ouvre et la petite vieille
elle sort et elle largue une énorme
caisse et elle se retourna fait
flageolets de chez lidl 400e
[Applaudissements]
vous avez rappelé jean-marie s'agit là
je vous y accueillir que des gens pas
super intelligent i thought bessin
village de tenir sa concurrente dans le
village écrit bienvenue chez les deux
baies maintenant un problème ils ont un
hôpital mais à un kilomètre de ce topic
talaia bien troupes et comme ils sont
tombés tout le temps il tombe dans le
trou peut alors il faut le réunion des
sages et plus intelligent du village qui
se donnent rendez vous et il faut qu'on
trouve un moyen pour ce trou alors on
avait dit écoutez c'est ce qu'on va
faire on va démolir l'hôpital on va le
construire à côté du trou comme ça quand
quelqu'un est au fond mais direct à
l'hôpital ça c'est plus intelligent mais
non ça ce qu'on va faire on va boucher
de trop à tout le monde y trace assez
intelligent et bien ou mal creuse à côté
de l'hôpital
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]